de l'émotion lors de la passation de
pouvoir avec l'ancien ministre au poste
sébastien lecornu pressenti un temps à
la justice c'est finalement aux autres
merck l'ancien député yale brunch iv a
pris ses fonctions je remercie emmanuel
macron elisabeth bornes pour leur
confiance je consacrerai toute mon
énergie à la mission qu'ils m'ont confié
j'agirai pour chacun de nos autres
maires avec une indéfectible ambitions
on est tous deux résident une très fière
d'elle est très satisfait de sa
nomination c'est une amie à ses proches
qui a fait un excellent travail qui a
déjà été élu meilleur député l'année
2002 21 je suis très heureux pour yaël
d'abord parce que c'est une amie parce
qu'elle a eue vous souvenez avec les
oppositions des débuts très difficiles
comme président de la commission des
lois elle n'a rien lâché elle a fini
comme une excellente présidente de la
commission des lois et ça lui fallait un
sacré caractère pour tenir parce que on
lui a pas fait de cadeau nommé dans un
ministère qualifié de difficile en
raison des crises sociales économiques
et écologiques que traverse les
territoires ultramarins il ya le brand
piv et bénéficie de la confiance de ses
homologues politique c'est qu'une
personne qui en plus de d'excellentes
qualités relationnelles c'est ce qu'il
faut saluer et rend tout
était accompagné
sébastien lecornu qui était le précédent
unis d outre-mer en nouvelle calédonie
par exemple pour préparer le référendum
qui s'est tenu en fin d'année dernière
elle a également mené à l'automne une
mission d'évaluation de l'application
des politiques
dans dans les antilles d'autres messages
d'encouragement ont été adressées à la
nouvelle ministre ancienne présidente de
la commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale
d'abord son ancien vice-président
stéphane mazars mes plus sincères voeux
de réussite à yaël boon peavey que j'ai
accompagné pendant cinq ans comme
vice-président et qui entre aujourd'hui
au gouvernement nous avions partagé de
voyage en outre-mer pendant ce
quinquennat mais aussi des députés
d'outre-mer toutes mes félicitations aux
nouveaux membres du gouvernement en
particulier à notre nouvelle ministre
des outre-mer yale brune privé je
connais ta capacité de travail et d
coûte ainsi que ton intérêt pour nos
territoires premier dossier sur les
cales yens brawn pie v se penchera la
crise sanitaire et le statut de la
nouvelle calédonie un travail de courte
armes d'abord ne connaissant pas sa
longévité au poste selon les résultats
du parti présidentiel aux futures
élections législatives